please welcome Joe Larry
welcome welcome to to Sweden very Naevia
and I can't help noticing that you're
wearing cushions issues yeah I did this
because I knew there was a runner here
but it didn't expect to be red sandals
so it's too cold or saying why you are
you a runner yourself
I used to be I miss it but I've had a
couple of knee surgeries on the Front's
of my knee torn cartilage from the years
I wrestled and I can now only run a pill
which if it's a real Hill is a problem
because I need to have a way to be
carried down
I'm very good up hill but I can't do
flats anymore I used in wrestling you
you really have wrestling legend doubles
now I competed for 20 years which was
probably a few years too long but I
never had any serious injuries that is
operable one surgeries until I stopped
competing and I coached until I was 47
in those years when I was working with
younger guys then I got hurt two of my
four knee surgeries were caused by two
of my children that wasn't even on top
of the Train I'm afraid of heights I
couldn't when we see these clips from
how you live and work it seems like a
wonderful life full of distractions well
I'm not I'm not easily distracted or
it's very I should stay another way
because I have three children I was used
to especially as a young person being
distracted but I never had an adore on
my office so my kids always felt
they could interrupt me I didn't want
them to feel that I was in some privacy
or of a trance or something I wanted to
be accessible you know and and so it's
very easy for me to get back to where I
was if somebody speaks to me but but now
you know you're the book called in one
person and it's it's a big book is this
huge story as many of your other books
are how do you work with them for
several years how do you find the
discipline you must need a very strong
discipline to work like that
I think you need discipline to do those
things that you don't love you have to
be disciplined to do those things things
that are allegedly good for you but I
don't think it requires much in the way
of discipline to do something you would
love to do and and you would be doing it
secretly or on the sly if you had other
obligations you write about growing up
coming of age and I wonder for yourself
huh which years where your formative
years I love being a father I love being
a grandfather I I gotta say that that I
like being 70 years old better than I
ever imagined I would I mean when I was
younger I thought surely I'll die young
that was a much more romantic thing to
I felt like I was the sort of person who
should die young but when it didn't
happen I don't know I I sort of like
this part better than I wasn't very
happy as a kid and you're right there I
almost always enjoy at least beginning a
novel in the point of view of someone
who's either a child about to become an
adolescent or in adolescence about to
have an experience that's too adult for
them it's not always a sexual passage
but often it is it's a moment between
being a kid and and suddenly almost
against one's will being more grown-up
than you ever intended
I like that moment in time but I
certainly never enjoyed that it's
nothing I miss so it's how was that time
for you I were you confused like many of
our characters I think I was most I was
I was angry as as a kid I was pretty
angry kid and and I III felt I never got
enough time alone and not enough time to
be alone and I loved wrestling for some
of the same focusing reasons that I
loved being a writer the repetition of
things which was not boring to me but
somehow very reassuring that that that
focus but I probably began wrestling for
some of the wrong reasons
because it wasn't outlet for being angry
air and being small right you know and I
I was attracted to it for those reasons
you write somewhere that in in your
latest book you write that we are formed
by what we desire I think that's more
true in the case of the book you're
quoting from which is narrated by a
bisexual man who's coming of sexual rage
in the 50s and 60s the more of a sexual
minority you are if you're gay if you
buy if you're transgender well you're
much more aware of how your desire forms
who you are because it's more of a
struggle if your sexual identity if who
you are sexually isn't something that
conventionally falls into place
well that's harder that's all I'm saying
it's it this is also a question of
tolerance and intolerance yes because
you often write about intolerance but
when are you intolerant to yourself well
I'm very much aware that that my my
greatest intolerance is for people who
are intolerant
but you see that that's not always a
virtue I'm I'm not I don't ever think of
myself is above hatred or above anger
you know it's it's it's an issue that
upsets me I didn't imagine when when I
was writing this this newest novel the
13th novel I didn't imagine that I would
still be writing about intolerance of
our sexual differences you know at this
time I thought I did that already I did
it in the late 70s in the world
according to GARP and I imagined naively
at that time well surely this will go
away well it hasn't it hasn't gone away
thank you so much for being here with us
tonight
please go Colin Kerry Kennedy
Oh